>>> THIS WEEK, FLORIDA'S
CONTROVERSIAL "DON'T SAY GAY"
BILL PASSED ITS FINAL STATE
SENATE COMMITTEE.
HERE TO COMMENT IS KATE
McKINNON.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HI,'LL COULDIN.
HELLO.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HI, KATE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> YEAH.
SORRY TO BARGE IN HERE OUT OF
COSTUME.
I HEARD ABOUT THIS LAW.
AND I THINK IT'S AMAZING.
>> OH, YOU DO?
>> YEAH.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, WHEN I WAS IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN THE '90s I WAS
SOME -- I WAS KIND OF LIKE
TORTURED BY THE CONSTANT USE OF
THE WORD "GAY."
"THAT'S SO GAY.
EW, YOU'RE GAY."
IT MADE ME FEEL HORRIBLE.
AND TO HEAR THAT RON DeSANTIS
HAS TAKEN A STAND AND SAID NO,
YOU CANNOT SAY GAY IN SCHOOL
ANYMORE.
I'M JUST LIKE -- I'M SO JAZZED.
AND IN FLORIDA OF ALL PLACES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
SO ACTUALLY, I FEEL LIKE THERE'S
BEEN A MISUNDERSTANDING.
THE LAW ACTUALLY MEANS THAT YOU
CAN'T ACKNOWLEDGE THAT GAY
EXISTS AT ALL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHAT?
>> YEAH.
LIKE TEACHERS CAN'T SPEAK ABOUT
GAY PEOPLE IN HISTORY.
OR IF A KID HAS A GAY FAMILY
MEMBER.
>> WHAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YEAH, AND IF A KID CONFIDES
THAT THEY'RE GAY TO A TEACHER,
THE TEACHER HAS TO OUT THEM TO
THEIR PARENTS.
>> OH, WHAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YEAH, SORRY TO BREAK THIS TO
YOU.
IT PROBABLY IS AFFECTING WHAT
YOU WERE GOING TO SAY.
>> YEAH.
OKAY.
THAT'S OKAY.
I'LL SAY SOMETHING.
IT'S JUST THAT THING OF LIKE
WHEN THEY SAY DON'T SAY GAY, YOU
KNOW, THEN IT'S LIKE STUCK IN
YOUR HEAD.
BUT IT'S FINE.
>> OKAY.
>> ANYWAY, I AM DEEPLY GAY OF --
SORRY.
CONCERNED.
DEEPLY CONCERNED.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE THIS IS GOING
TO MAKE KIDS GAY AND TRANS --
SORRY, DEPRESSED AND SUICIDAL.
AND I THINK THESE LAWS ARE
LESBIANS.
SORRY, UNCONSCIONABLE.
>> I THINK YOU ENDED UP SAYING
GAY A COUPLE TIMES.
>> I'M TRYING TO MAKE SENSE OF
ALL THIS.
LIKE THIS DON'T SAY GAY LAW HAVE
A PURPOSE?
>> WELL, I THINK I GUESS IT'S SO
KIDS AREN'T GOING HOME WITH
QUESTIONS THAT PARENTS DON'T
WANT TO ANSWER?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE IDEA IS.
>> SO ONE KID CAN SAY I LIVE
WITH MY PARENTS BUT ANOTHER ONE
HAS TO SAY I LIVE IN A HOUSE
WITH TWO ADULT MEN WHO BOUGHT ME
WHEN I WAS YOUNG?
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT'LL BE -- THEY'LL BE LESS
CONFUSED THEN.
>> IT DOES SOUND LIKE IT WOULD
BE MORE CONFUSING.
>> LOOK, COLIN, IF THE '90s WERE
RIGHT AND GAY MEANS BAD, THEN
THIS IS THE GAYEST LAW I'VE EVER
SEEN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IF YOU CAN'T SAY IT, YOU MIGHT
AS WELL SING IT.
♪ GAY, GAY, GAY ♪
♪ GAY, GAY, GAY, GAY ♪
♪ GAY, GAY, GAY, GAY, GAY ♪
>> KATE McKINNON, EVERYONE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪ GAY, GAY, GAY, GAY, I GA GUY ♪